let's go to our next caller from the 772
area code Carlos from 772 go ahead hi
David this is Andrew from South Florida
Andrew I can hear you perfectly you
introduced yourself beautifully let's go
right into your question okay so my
question is regarding the me to
movements I was having a conversation
with my friends about this and someone
brought up an interesting point it was
when two individuals of a company are in
a consensual relationship and there's a
large power dynamic between the two like
one is an executive and one is like a
lower-level employee yeah could that be
considered like statutory rape since the
lower level employee might not be able
to consent properly since there's a huge
power dynamic ah for me that's a no-no I
don't think so I think statutory rape
relates to someone having the lacking
the capacity so statutory rape means
what it means that if you are an adult
and you engage in sexual intercourse or
a sexual encounter with someone who's
below a certain age even if they believe
that they are consenting of their own
free will the state has determined
they're too young to really be giving
informed consent so like they might
think this is something they want to do
but we think that the twelve-year-old
brain or the 14 or the 16 year old brain
is simply not developed enough to give
that kind of informed consent when
you're talking about a power dynamic at
work someone may be influenced by the
fact that they are being approached or
courted by an individual with more power
within the organization but they don't
lack the mental capacity in the sense
that statutory rape was was meant to
protect against oh no I don't I don't
think that that's reasonable okay well
someone I was listening to a
conversation on
they were talking about the Matt Lauer
case and I guess the woman that he was
having an affair with she said that she
consented at first but then later on
retracted her consent and said I was
just taken by how much power he had and
I wasn't in the right mindset to know
now let me ask you a question about that
because I haven't seen that when you say
she later retracted consent do you mean
during the course of the affair or
literally in the middle of a sexual
encounter uh no it was actually after
everything came out into the public eye
I guess so she would read it she read
the fact that she participated in the in
the affair I'm not sure exactly what
happened while the affair was going on
but on the shuttle she said later on
that yeah after everything came out that
she had basically regretted consenting
and said I was just taken by how much
power he had okay all right well that's
a perfectly fair thing for her to say
but I'm not hearing anything that would
make that statutory rape okay well thank
you all right no problem thank you
appreciate the call